when it comes to mandating what goes
into or happens to a person's body
there's an intimacy there
there's something inalienable about
the body and the physiological processes
in the body there's an intimacy that's
broken an invasion into
what should be private by the state and
that's why
i think that these um health care
mandates are trespassing or crossing a
line that they should never cross
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the pleasure and honor
today of sitting with julie panesi who
is a doctor of philosophy ethics and
ancient philosophy and until this year
was teaching at the university of
western ontario in the huron college
welcome julie
thank you so much delighted to be here
well i'm very excited to talk to you um
i'm a biologist as my listeners will
know but i have a deep interest in
philosophy
especially the philosophy of science but
of course
all the philosophies are tied together
and this year we have seen the
interaction of the philosophy of science
with the questions of ethics so i'm very
much interested to hear what you have to
tell us about the way these things
interact but before you do that could
you
uh tell us the story of what's happened
to you this year
sure so until
last september i taught philosophy
especially ethical theory applied ethics
history of ethics
ancient philosophy
political philosophy history political
philosophy those kinds of things at
western university huron college in
particular in london ontario
and
when they started discussing
mandates in the educational sector
in the summer i guess it was and then we
got word about two weeks before school
started that my institution was going to
be implementing one of the vaccine
mandates i wrote to some of the senior
administration at huron so my chair
president and dean and just expressed my
concerns i i didn't say that i was
opposed
to to providing proof of vaccination but
i expressed my concerns about the
mandate generally speaking
um and i didn't get a response from that
email it was a long email with footnotes
you know i mean you ask an academic to
provide thoughts on something that's
what you're gonna get
um and i didn't get a response to that
email and then
uh i think it was sort of the first week
of september i mean classes here uh
start first second week of september so
it was imminent the start of classes and
i knew that teaching assignments needed
to be sorted out i had a big
amphitheater style class i was about to
teach and um i didn't know if i was
going to be teaching or not and then i
got a word an email from my dean saying
so can i assume from this and he was
referencing that long email i had sent a
couple weeks earlier so can i assume
from this that you plan not to comply
with the mandate
uh initially i didn't respond because i
knew based on what had happened with
other colleagues that as soon as you
respond to that email saying
i won't comply then you most people were
getting termination letters within like
hours if not you know or that day or
something so i didn't respond but then i
thought about it and i thought well i i
no i don't respond i object and i think
that it's important uh it's important to
be clear about that i mean both for the
sake of
transparency and
for me sorting out what's happening
going forward and and for them to
get someone else to teach the you know
for for all involved and uh so i made it
very clear that i planned not come to
comply
with their covet policy which didn't
just require proof of vaccination to be
uploaded uh but also to mask fully and
completely in the classroom
and i stated clearly that i would not do
any of those things and then
while that email exchange was happening
i can't remember the exact day but i
recorded a video that was meant as sort
of a
last lecture on ethics to my incoming
class that year to talk a bit about the
ethics of mandating
a medical choice and that came out
i think it was labor day
and
it
un you know
unanticipated by myself sort of went
viral i was away from the day for the
day and i came back to my phone and my
phone was just exploding and i had no
idea what happened and anyway long story
short i got a letter from
my dean
that was a termination with cause letter
both for refusing to comply with the
mandate and then also doing so in a
public way
wild yes i've seen that video and i will
put a link to it in the description of
this podcast so people can look at it
and i think
um
watching it was
extremely emotional for me
it clearly was for you making it and and
i think i know why because i remember
quite well
the last time that i
taught my students
and events had unfolded
very rapidly and it became clear that
the college did not intend to create a
safe working environment and i was
literally meeting with my students
in a public park because it was not safe
to be on
campus
and you know
one invests in a career
and if one's any good at this particular
career one invests
in individual human beings that you come
to know and care about and to face them
and realize that you are being
ushered out the door by an institution
that really has no business in that
relationship
is um it's a powerful moment
it is and i think you you're not just
investing in human relationships or at
least i mean you tell me what you think
about this but i feel like
over my career and and really from the
moment maybe early in grad school when i
realized that i wanted to teach in a
university context i feel like you're
you're investing in
the process of of understanding better
and trying to develop your skills to do
with how to teach and and for me that it
was very much
an ancient sort of socratic model where
teaching is not about figuring out how
do i get the ideas in here into the
empty vessels that are my students
brains it wasn't that
it was a it was a very complex
interesting process for me trying to
understand
like how do you
how do you how do you become the impetus
that
helps to grow
not just the ideas but the
the mechanism the machine that helps to
generate those ideas in their minds
and maybe that's sort of unique to
philosophy especially
or what we're trying to do is develop
critical thinking but i can't tell you
how many
you know how many times in the classroom
usually on the first day of class that
opening
lecture where you're trying to explain
okay what are we going to do here what's
the project what can you expect from me
what do i expect from you and my lecture
is always something like
you know i'm not here to give you the
facts especially in philosophy right
it's not really about facts it's about
building skills and understanding how to
develop and exercise that critical
thinking muscle so that
when you get information from the world
you don't just respond to it as an
animal would or as a computer would but
that you know your
your your mind kind of works on it
and you decide yourself what to ascend
to and what not to ascend to
and so
what you've invested in is not just your
particular students or your particular
relationships with them but becoming the
sort of person who
understands how to do that better and
better every year hopefully i mean
that's the goal i'm not saying we're all
all aiming at perfection in that respect
or at the same pace but
that was the goal for me certainly and
there's a loss to that you know there's
um
i mean i'm doing different things now
and i guess you could argue teaching in
different ways but
that intimate one-on-one relationship in
a classroom
with a student where you're so
sensitive to the vulnerability of
someone who is placing their trust in
you
as an educator is i think a unique human
experience
yeah it's um
it's fascinating
i believe it was a day maybe it was two
days before
my uh
famous incident erupted outside my
classroom
i put a
a diagram on the board a model that i
was working on
about
witch hunts and how they work
and it was on my mind because a witch
hunt was developing around me so it's
not a completely independent data point
but nonetheless i described
this thing to them
and
then two days later we were
meeting in a public park
for the last time and i remember what i
said to them was uh take careful notes
because i do not think we will pass this
way again
and
i knew
i could tell that i was in the process
of becoming an object lesson right i
went from teaching about something to
becoming the something
and
as you say it put me in a position where
i'm now teaching at a very different
scale it's not like i've stopped doing
the thing i trained for but nonetheless
it was a very powerful visceral feeling
to realize
that
the abstraction
had
become
real and that it had come for me and i
know that in looking at your video
i see something
very similar right you you're an
ethicist
and at the moment that you were ejected
from your job
you were confronted
with an ethical question
that you were uniquely equipped
to understand and yet failed the test
according to my employers
no no you passed the test you passed the
test with flying colors and
i guess the problem is that because we
are living in a world in which so much
is upside down
the spoils of having passed the test
with flying colors is the loss of a job
that you had invested
everything in
and
that is such a
what a remarkable moment
in history that that's where we are that
um that doing the right thing
especially when you know exactly what
that right thing is
causes this kind of
allergic reaction of the system
to you that it needs to target you
because the last thing it can it can
stand is to have you successfully
demonstrate this ancient principle
that's right i think it's
uh i mean you use the word remarkable
and i think we often use that now as a
synonym for something good but but it
isn't really the term remarkable is just
to be
something worthy of being remarked on
focused on and i think you're right
we're living in a punctuated moment in
history and the sad fact about that for
academia and centers of higher learning
is that whatever higher learning is now
it is not learning how to be
a free and open thinker
i mean having spent time in academia and
going to conferences and probably
sitting in on senate meetings and things
like that you will know that it's
impossible to get a group of academics
to agree about anything
as it should be
right there should always be i mean they
always disagree whether it's within a
subject within your discipline or it's a
it's a department you know meeting about
how we're going to change uh you know
guidelines for progression for
undergraduates or
whatever it is right um
the fact that
within
presumably nearly every
post-secondary institution in north
america
there is apparently a 90 well in canada
a 98
compliance rate with any kind of mandate
any kind of policy and i don't know what
the percentage is on people speaking out
against it very very low
that is just to put it in very
unacademic terms weird it's just
very weird and very anomalous
and the fact that you have something so
significant happening and you have so
few
we call them
intellectuals exercising their minds and
entering into an arena public debate i
mean we should be having town hall
meetings citizens assemblies the
equivalencies at university we should be
having student unions up in arms we
should be having student groups forming
left right and center to to consider
this to challenge this i
the fact that we don't have that is in
my mind a litmus test for
where we're at in society intellectually
and what counts as being a good member
of an intellectual discipline what
counts as being a good citizen
and what counts is being compliant what
counts as being a good cog in the wheel
and that is antithetical to every
every
aspect of the ethos of academia which
started right in plato's academy
in greece 2000 years ago
and we have spent
2 000 years with the odd blip and dip
and
abandonment but getting back on track
only to find ourselves at a place that
he would be ashamed of i have no doubt
ashamed of
we're in this kind of vacuum where
it's not just that you can't disagree
but questions are no long questioning is
no longer tolerated the very act of
questioning is no longer tolerated
we've gone from
democracies i think in both both canada
and the u.s
that prided themselves on protecting
intellectual freedom and freedom of
speech at all costs to now
normalizing
and introducing legislation
to
uh
i guess the idea is to prevent hate
speech but basically to create such a
censored system
that
no outlying thought is even possible
anymore
i went back to my twitter timeline a few
weeks ago and i searched it for the term
dark age
i joined twitter in 2009 and in 2009 i
was already mentioning that we were
headed into a dark age
and i truly believe that that's where we
are and the fact that our universities
have turned on us and they've become
places of a suspicious level of
agreement
right as you say getting academics to
agree on anything is virtually
impossible and yet we have this
incredible level of tsunami
and it is trying to tell us something
i mean a these places are
incapable of doing the job for which we
built them at that level of agreement
they cannot do it and so we are sending
young people there
and they are no doubt coming away with
something but it isn't an enhanced
capacity to think in fact it's the
opposite
and
the philosophical implications i mean
you know this is your area of specialty
you'll you'll see it very clearly and
weirdly
i guess my area of specialty is
parallel but at a a different scale
but you know as you say this goes back
to plato and we've been making progress
on these difficult questions and now
we're headed in the reverse direction
right and we could say the same thing
about our species
what we understand
is in some sense the accumulation
of hundreds of thousands of years of
discovery
and for us now
to be
willingly taking it apart
is just it's frightening it's
frightening and i do think it has
something to do with a deep
vulnerability in the human psyche that
we are watching ancient processes
and people are not understanding the
danger that we are creating for
ourselves
so i'll play devil's advocate for a
minute because it just seems so i mean i
accuse sort of the other side of not
doing this so i'm trying to develop you
know practice where i have a tendency to
do this more often than i might
otherwise but i'm always trying to
understand what people on the other side
say about this about people who are
trying to challenge
uh accepted norms within academia or
within politics or whatever
and and i think that one of the views is
that well
question asking is all well and good but
at some point we have to stop at some
point we have to accept that there are
certain givens so that we have a
foundation on which to build the rest of
our system
and so i take it that that within
science and you could speak to this much
better than i within science within
medicine
uh medical ethics within politics
that there's this agreement now
that we have we have achieved a certain
level of certainty and i think it's not
a coincidence that the term science is
being used as a synonym for something
like perfection and never mind the
bastardization of the word
falsifiability i mean it seems to have
come to be mean the opposite of what i
understand it to mean anyway it means
that you can't question anything now
right
it means that science is beyond
questioning beyond reproach
um
but i i it's an interesting idea right i
mean is it the case that if we are a
human species who
uh if we're rational we're capable of
critical thought we're capable of not
just responding directly to our
environment but thinking reflectively
about it and so we're sort of engaged in
this process of question and answer
ought that go on indefinitely or are we
supposed to reach a point at which we
feel like nope i've got the answers i'm
settled um now we just build on that
and so
you know maybe the question now is well
what are if that's true
what are the settled principles that
we're taking for granted on which we're
building the rest of the system
and i take it that one of them
is within science that the scientific
system that's composed of things like a
peer-reviewed journals double-blind
studies
and the involvement of pharmaceutical
companies
is i won't say a perfect system
but
a system that has a lot of integrity
and that we can count on its output and
therefore we shouldn't question its
output because to do so is not only a
kind of waste of mental energy because
we've already exerted that mental energy
to get to where we are now
but it's a kind of heresy
right it's like galileo questioning the
teachings of the catholic church we
ought not do that that's beyond reproach
beyond question
no well i uh
i will take up your challenge
here's the way i think of it
if you imagine um
an ancient hunting party
a band of men headed out into the bush
to hunt
creatures for sustenance
and you can imagine maybe one of them
is a little more
cerebral a little more prone to look
into the sky and wonder about things
and maybe they're passing some trees and
this guy notices that the way the leaves
flip back and forth like imagine
an aspen leaf that flips back and forth
implies something about
binary
right and that
the universe could be encoded maybe in
binary
well that guy's
right that guy's right
right he's not wrong he's discovered
something
amazing and maybe thousands of years
ahead of schedule
but it's not the time for it right
his people might starve if he gets
overly mesmerized by the leaves flipping
back and forth and the point is
get up we got to go hunt right so i
agree with this principle and you could
do the same thing with a
military situation you can't have people
exercising democracy in the middle of a
battlefield right they have to actually
do the job
but
that is not the university
the university's purpose is a place
where it is safe to do those things and
frankly where it is safe to question
everything no matter how secure
forever that is its design that is its
purpose
and the idea
that people
like you and me find ourselves ejected
from that structure because the
structure where it is supposed to be
like an intellectual sandbox where we
are entitled to question everything and
open any idea and suddenly we are not
able to do that and there's suspicious
levels of agreement
is
it's like a
red flag warning that society has just
tripped over something very very
dangerous and
i think
what i see more than anything
is that what
we have
civilization
is
incredibly important it is the stuff
that makes the lives that we live
possible
and most people because they've never
seen what life is like without it
don't understand the danger of playing
around with the fundamentals that allow
it to function
and what we are now doing is we're very
focused on what doesn't work in
civilization
and there's a lot of people very eager
for solution making in part because they
don't understand the danger if we unmake
that system
what we are left with is
horrifying
and
it is the university it is the
philosophers it is the scientists who
are supposed to be on alert
looking for us to make those kinds of
errors and saying wait a minute no
you're doing this wrong right
yes there are things that we have to fix
but unmaking the system that we've got
in the hopes that something better will
replace it is the height of insanity and
here's how we know
and
so i wonder a little bit you know i'm
talking to
a philosopher confronted with
what's frankly not a very difficult
ethical question
that we seem to be getting wrong
and
i know this also isn't a difficult
evolutionary puzzle
and yet we're getting it wrong and your
point about pharmaceutical companies
there's a perverse incentive
we know that corruption is an ancient
phenomenon
you have to have a system that is
capable of pulling the rip cord
at the point that something captures an
essential process
and steers it to its own profit
and
you know i
you didn't end up saying whether you had
gotten vaccinated i can imagine an
ethicist
uh taking a principled stand against
demonstrating
that you had been vaccinated even if you
had
but
go ahead
well i was just going to say i'm i'm
very happy to say that that no i haven't
and i never will
but i do think it's important to
separate
the
personal medical choice
from the political choice to abide by
and endorse the mandates and you know
the
we can talk about this a little later
but the trucker convoy in ottawa um
many of the truckers there are
vaccinated are very public about that
but have just been very clear that we
don't want to live in a system
of in a system of mandates
right
um you know even the idea of a mandate
if we think about that for a minute
when you're mandating
something that is a matter of health
a personal medical choice
in some sense a mandate is either
unnecessary or unjustified
it's unnecessary
for those who would have
done it anyway complied anyway
and it's arguably unjustified if we
consider
the most important
thing to preserve for humans for quality
of life and for flourishing and for
happiness
is autonomy and that word autonomy
comes from two greek words that means
self-rule right and someone might say
well we don't let people do just
whatever they want so you know you have
to get a driver's license to drive a car
and things like that
yes that's true
but
when it comes to mandating what goes
into or happens to a person's body
there's an intimacy there there's
something inalienable about
the body and the physiological processes
in the body there's an intimacy that's
broken an invasion into uh what should
be private by the state and that's why
i think that these um health care
mandates are trespassing or crossing a
line that they should never cross
and you know i've had some really
interesting discussions with with
academics with physicians
uh about whether or not in principle
there are situations where um a health
care mandate would be appropriate and
my thinking and i've thought about this
a lot you know and there's often this
reference to the smallpox case
massachusetts versus jacobson right all
of that and
my feeling about it is though i want to
do more thinking about it is that if
healthcare mandates are ever justified
there needs to be an incredibly high and
almost impossibly high threshold that
has to be met that involves things like
the severity of the viral threat which
is not anything like what we're seeing
right now right so my point to all of
this is that to mandate something is not
just to impose
a blanket rule on a group of people for
whom it doesn't matter much
right um because either
there's a there's a percentage of that
group that will do the thing anyway and
there's a percentage of that group that
will not do the thing
and will either do it because of the
mandate under circumstances of coercion
and that's a serious threat to autonomy
or people who will refuse to abide by
the mandate anyway so what's the purpose
so really the only group it's affecting
is a coerced group of people
right yeah
i agree with this completely um
and
i know that we never had the discussion
about the threshold of severity and the
threshold of safety that would be that
would have to be met before such a thing
would make any sense
and i also know that
biologically
there was a shell game that was played
here
where people have gotten used to using a
heuristic to do their thinking and their
heuristic is vaccines are on balance
pretty good
and i think it's more than that in
canada anyway the the heuristic is uh
vaccines are perfect immunity makers and
you're virtuous if you get on board i
mean it's just i think it's a strong um
what do we want to call it it's a strong
messaging system it's a strong ethos
it is very strong and
i believe that it is largely
justified there's something
very beautiful about a vaccine that
actually works right it's a very elegant
intervention
into the immune system on the other hand
people mistake the syringe
for
evidence of how effective and elegant an
intervention is and they did not
properly register how novel
this particular vaccine was
and so they sort of had gotten used to
seeing a syringe and thinking that's not
a big deal i'll take it i'm better off
with it than without it
and those of us who understood what was
being said about the contents of that
syringe we're having a different
reaction which is wow
that is a radical departure from the way
these things typically
work we're taking this radical departure
at a moment when the disease in question
is certainly very unfortunate and
dangerous but
not nearly at the level that this short
a time horizon on this new technology is
sufficient to say what they were saying
which is this is highly effective and
it's safe
and my feeling what i said on our
podcast
was i know you don't know it's safe
i can't say that it's harmful but i can
say by analogy if you walk into a room
and there's a gun on the table and you
put the gun to your head and you pull
the trigger and it goes click
did it harm you
no
was it safe
no
and what we knew at the point that they
were telling us these vaccines were safe
was that they couldn't possibly know
anything about their effects 5 years 10
years 20 years down the road so they
were lying that's so interesting i
hadn't thought about it that way beware
greeks bearing gifts right it's a bit of
a trojan horse phenomenon so if we
present to you this thing that you know
nothing about or or may may have maybe
different in form than what you believe
it to be
but we present it to you
in a using a vehicle that you perceive
to be non-threatening
you'll take it and you'll just assume
that you're doing the same thing you
always do when your doctor says oh
you're due for a vaccination oh am i doc
okay
well i think the um you know evidence to
to
support your hypothesis is that people
were surprised when they were getting
coveted after getting vaccinated because
they didn't realize that there was this
this this distinction between um
sterilizing and non-sterilizing vaccines
and i think there's
i i think that failure to distinguish is
preserved to this day i think people are
still surprised because that
narrative of um
vaccination achieving
perfection
and protection of the system and
integrity of the system and now i'm
i'm literally immune i can go and do
anything
and and one thing that's very
interesting to me is i feel like
alongside this concept of biological
immunity once we've become vaccinated
i think there's also this kind of
insidiously
horrific but also sort of beautiful
metaphor of being
morally immune because now you can enter
the public sp space the moral sphere
as a presentable human being
as a responsible member of society as
someone beyond reproach as a moral
exemplar a hero even
you know i mean
we've seen this um
that this this era of conspicuous
medicine where people after they get
back i haven't seen it so much with the
boosters but when people got their first
and second shots it's like they come out
of the the clinic or wherever uh and
then it's almost like you're walking the
red carpet and there are these walls
with the vaccination stickers and you
can get your photo taken up against them
like it's like a conspicuous event and
why is that important well it's because
it's important to solidify i mean i
think you know it's important to
solidify your place
in the social arrangement as someone who
has
sort of championed um the banner of
goodness for a group of people right so
it's not just in getting vaccinated that
you've achieved
in
virological immunity but you've also
achieved a kind of moral immunity no one
can criticize you anymore no one can
call you evil as they have done to me
and maybe you you know uh absolutely and
again it's this strange inversion where
earlier we were talking about the fact
that the purpose of the university is
the sandbox where we can discuss
anything so that we will we will see
things coming right it is the place to
talk about the implication of the leaves
and all of that
and at the moment it doesn't tolerate
those of us who do that well it has
thrown us out in favor of people who
rush to consensus
and
the
the issue of vaccination
is one in which i i have no doubt
there are some people with an irrational
fear
of vaccines
who
correctly feared in this case a vaccine
they knew nothing about but would have
done so no matter how safe it was
and then there were many which is just a
coincidence that they happen to be
fearful of this one right i don't know
uh if the pre-trans fallacy is an
important item that in your discipline
is that ring a bell
pre-trans fallacy is a case where
there's a naive position
and then there's an educated position
which is the inverse of the naive
position and then there's an enlightened
position that flips back to the
original position so for example
if you're at the zoo
and a child is looking at a chimpanzee
and it says what a funny monkey and the
teacher says oh that's not a monkey
that's an ape right the child is
actually right that it's a monkey it's
also an a i didn't know right but didn't
know right a phylogenetic systematist
who was sitting there would say well yes
it's an ape but it's also a monkey right
so
this is one of these cases where a true
anti-vaxxer
would have
feared this vaccine because they fear
all vaccines but then there are many
others of us who are not anti-vaxxers by
any stretch of the imagination i mean
i'm as vaccinated as probably anyone
you'll ever meet because
i did tropical biology i'm vaccinated
against rabies against yellow fever all
kinds of things you're loaded up i'm
loaded up and i feel good about it i
like being able to you know i work with
bats i like being able to pick up a bat
and not worry if it bites me
that i'm gonna get rabies right um but
in this case
the
the brochure did not correctly explain
the risk that people were taking and did
not compare that risk to the risk that
they were taking confronting the virus
which of course is so age stratified
that it there is no one-size-fits-all
policy a healthy 20 year old is in a
very different position than a
60-year-old that's right and what that
means i mean the practical upshot of
that is that the the healthier you are
the fewer comorbidities you have the
younger you are the greater your risk is
because the risk benefit ratio is is is
more imbalanced right
it's actually extremely steep because
not only do you face very low risk from
covid but if the vaccine does harm you
you have a very long life in which to
suffer that harm whereas somebody who is
harmed at 80 years old might lose a
decade
but you know a 16 year old might lose
four or five decades i mean the
potential to have children and future
generations right i mean it's yeah i
agree that it's quite a steep risk
and
the problem is
the corruption of our system
is so severe
that at the point your system is lying
to you i mean a lot of my friends got
caught by the lies because they were
used to public health lying to them
public health lies because that's part
of its job right it oversimplifies
things in order to get you to do the
right thing
and so the fact that it was lying to
noble lie a noble lie right they assumed
that's why they were being lied to now
heather and i looked at this and thought
wait a minute
those lies
don't look like noble lies
they look like corrupt lies
and those corrupt lies
resulted in who knows how many tens of
billions of dollars being made by
particular folks
and those folks
play a game where they use government
to
coerce
use of their products
right it's a very unusual
market where
you know it's not supply and demand it's
supply and demand date
and
that
means
that there's a reason to be hyper
vigilant
about the danger that what you're being
told isn't actually in your medical
interest
this is um i mean we actually i think
have sort of a regulatory capture triad
because it's not just the pharmaceutical
companies and the government but there's
the media as the third piece right and
so the conflicts of interest overlap on
each side of that that triad
um
working in
the history of medicine history of
medical ethics there were a couple of
things on the radar that made me very
skeptical about these vaccines early on
one of which was the ssri crisis
especially for for adolescents and the
high suicidality rates
that really start you know came on the
scene in the 90s and then of course the
opioid crisis and you know the
the literature and medical ethics
surrounding those two
related crises
uh was quite
responsible and skeptical i think you
know i mean even um
you know the the the chief editors of
the top medical journals in the world
said you know i think that that science
is corrupted there's a problem with um
the peer-reviewed uh
art journal article process
um and i'm not sure it can be trusted
moving forward and we need a massive
overhaul
but i don't think that any of that
information trickled down in the right
ways certainly didn't trickle down to
the average person no no
non-specialist that i have spoken to has
heard about either maybe the opioid
crisis but not really
where it came from and you know how
regulatory capture was a significant
problem and how you know physicians were
courted by pharmaceutical companies to
downplay
uh you know the risks of the side
effects of these of these drugs and also
to create um a system of fabricated
desires right where people
didn't realize that they had a problem
that they now require a meta medication
for and then they think oh yeah gee i
really would like to feel a little
happier and sleep a little better i
didn't realize it but now that you put
it that way i think i do you know anyway
i mean there's
there was a history of
i think conservatively two decades
where we have seen the harms of
regulatory capture we know the kind of
money that's at stake in the
pharmaceutical industry we know the kind
of collusion between pharmaceutical
companies uh and government and so that
doesn't mean i mean i always like try to
be careful when i'm thinking or speaking
not to assume that wherever there's a
conflict of interest
the decision will always be made in
favor of the wrong interest
right i don't want to make that
suggestion because you could have a very
benevolent billionaire right who always
makes the you know who really does
genuinely care for for humanity
but
whenever there's a conflict of interest
like that and we're talking about tens
of billions of dollars in stock that are
now
being dumped by these spidey ceos but
um whenever you're talking about that
kind of money
it's incumbent upon us as the average
citizen as the average drug taker is the
average vaccine recipient to be
skeptical and to ask questions is this
necessary am i really in a state where
i'm facing
a viral threat that has a high infection
fatality rate for my
age group
am i
and then on the other side
what kind of trials have we seen how's
that data looking you know we had the uh
the data from pfizer released and well
gee it's not looking so good and we just
had i was just reading this morning
about a german
insurance company that you know they're
saying
that
i think 10 million people 10 million
vaccine recipients there's data on them
now and it's it's i think the word from
the ceo is it's shocking and requires
further investigation so
it's it's not surprising to me that this
regulatory capture can happen
what's surprising and concerning and
needs to be addressed moving forward i
think is that the average person
has the critical thinking skills to ask
these questions
and be more reflective
and that physicians
right that who
are
should be responsible for administering
these
or not conveniently right this practice
of vaccinating for covet has been taken
out of the i think fiduciary
relationship between physician and
patient and put in i mean in our case
you can go to like your local sports
arena and
get it from who knows who right
um
[Music]
we need to be more critical we need to
be
we need to
i was talking to
jordan peterson a while he had this
beautiful metaphor about his tool shed
you know he was thinking he's saying
that that thinking and critical thinking
is like you've got all these tools in
the shed and you need exactly the right
tool for the specific job and you need
to keep them rest free and sharp and
ready to go and know where they are but
thinking is like that you know and this
has been
um this covet test which is not a
biological test by that i mean it's a
test of our
ability to think through
um
a massive onslaught of information
coming at us from a perceived set of
authorities and i think we've failed
miserably it doesn't mean
that failure needs to become it's not
inevitable that we will always fail
but we need moving forward
to look back historically
and figure out how we got ourselves to
this place and how we can do better we
were talking earlier about about the
past and about historical events um
like what happened in europe in the 30s
and 40s and why we're so reluctant to
make analogies
to that that point in time
um but it seems to me that if we don't
if we close off the possibility of
looking at the past as a possible way of
informing how we move forward we are
disabling ourselves beyond measure
yeah we uh
so i've been focused on
pharma and regulatory capture for many
years because of a project i did in in
graduate school that
revealed a flaw in the drug safety
system which as far as i know is still
not corrected it's a flaw that makes
things look less toxic than they
actually are
but most people although
until a couple years ago would have had
some sense of yes pharma corruption is a
real thing
during covid
completely suspended their disbelief
amnesia
yeah and i have
the
sense that we are
we walked into the largest version of a
game that pharma plays
every day of every week
throughout the year right pharma is
constantly in the process
of trying to define a need for which
they have
a pharmacological solution
trying to expand the definition of that
need so it covers the maximum number of
people
trying to convince doctors that the
solution that they have is in fact the
best one and it is the should be the
standard of care
trying to persuade government that the
solution is safe enough to be worth
the costs
and
that what happened is that kovid opened
up the largest
new market sector conceivable
and that this game has been played out
where
i don't know i'm sure you had the same
experience i did where
somehow pharma was speaking even through
my friends
right pharma was telling me that i was
being irresponsible to discuss what i
was perfectly well qualified to see as a
scientist who trained to understand
complex systems as somebody who has
studied immunobot immunobiology i was
perfectly capable at looking looking at
these vaccines and saying well wait a
minute
there are all kinds of ways this could
go wrong they haven't been around long
enough for us to know in which of these
ways they will go wrong and i'm being
mandated to take it over what kind of
risk
right those are all
and mandated not to talk about it
because we live in this era of this this
credentialism this expertise and oh and
by the way what we mean by an expert is
only these particular people
we've sort of deemed these people
appropriate mouthpieces or appropriate i
wouldn't even say sort of um subjects
for debate because we don't even see
debate happening between you know
amongst themselves we're just seeing um
only these people who are considered to
be experts are allowed to speak of these
things
and
you're not an expert if you disagree
not if you don't have the appropriate
credentials or background or education
but what makes you a non-expert is your
disagreement
with the ideology of the system
that's exactly right and it is the most
upsetting thing for anybody who studied
logic in any way the idea that it is
your very disagreement with the
consensus that renders you unqualified
when the point is well then
what is the nature of this consensus
right if there are those of us who
ordinarily would be considered qualified
and if we were in agreement you'd say we
were qualified but as soon as we
disagree we are not qualified then that
consensus isn't anything it's it's
coercion itself
and you know the whole idea that the
reason we are not allowed to disagree
is that the consensus has been reached
and for you to violate it is going to
cause distrust in it but the point is
yes
if if it was coerced in the first place
it's not a natural consensus right
consensus arises over time because
something becomes clear it doesn't arise
in five minutes because we browbeat
anybody who disagrees
well consensus i mean i think that um i
think that probably isn't the colloquial
understanding of consensus i think it
probably is just
uh sort of like we took a referendum and
this is what right it's just it just is
agreement but what you're suggesting is
that consensus is
you know the nature of the term involves
a process or a history you need to
understand how you reached it and you
mentioned logic and what's so important
when we're looking at
arguments as we're trying to understand
which ones are sound and which ones are
not sound and what makes an argument
sound is not that the conclusion is
right
or the same as someone else's
but that there is the appropriate set of
reasons given that are connected in the
right ways to support that conclusion so
there's a historicity to soundness
right and i think as you're saying
there's a historicity to consensus and
so we do need to look at what goes into
the process and that's why closing off
debate and focusing only on conclusion
whether it's within science and academia
or i mean right now in our house of
commons in canada we're seeing this from
our from our prime minister which is
just reiterating the same old line over
and over and over again vaccines are
safe and effective um protesters are
nazis you know this is hoping but but
without any kind of willingness to
engage in that sort of debate and you
know as you're talking or as we're
having this conversation i'm sort of
thinking that
like let's say it's the case that we as
human beings are just getting all kinds
of things wrong and that we're so
self-destructive right now we're just um
we're blind
we are um controlled by our fear of
ostracization
we are terrified of being labeled
heretics and cast outside of the group
we want desperately to belong to
whatever this uh collectivist do your
part sort of system mentality is
and that's causing an awful lot of harm
it seems
why are we doing that you know and as a
as a student of history i can't help but
think of
ancient tragedies you know and and a
tragedy we use that term i think loosely
and improperly now to refer to any sort
of disaster but a tragedy technically
speaking is one in which there's a
character who has your protagonist or
hero who has a character flaw that
forces him to make choices that
ultimately lead to his downfall
so i feel like
we are
living a tragedy now and that we are as
a
this group of humans at this moment
in history
we are this protagonist that has
a maybe more than one tragic flaw
blindness or myopia sort of one of them
right we're focused only on
um
one kind of threat one kind of harm
um and only one escape route out of it
and we're willing to vilify
cancel d platform kill maybe
anyone who challenges it
right
and in the process of doing that we are
quite possibly leading to our own
self-destruction and
if the ancient playwrights are right the
only thing that solves that kind of
tragic flaw is self-reflection
but we often can't i mean the tragic
heroes
they never get it until the end of the
story they need to things need to become
extreme that tragic flaw needs to play
itself out until the point of
destruction
where that person has lost everything
um they've lost family members maybe
they've even died themselves but usually
not right usually it's destruction of
all persons around him or her they've
lost their city they've been blinded
whatever it is and then
it's only that level of destruction
that puts us into a place where we are
left with nothing else but to consider
how we've gotten ourselves here
yeah that's a beautiful description and
i think it's so
so apt
if you think about
where we actually are
for
a year
those of us who
looked at the evidence and said you know
this doesn't look like a natural
spillover event
all of the evidence points toward this
being an engineered virus that leaked
out of a laboratory
and lo and behold it turns out
that the people who
offshored the work to that laboratory
are also in charge of the cover-up of
the leak they are also in charge of our
public health
response
and
i keep trying to put it in proper
context you know we live in
a
universe
that is many billions of years old
life has evolved on this planet for
three and a half to four
billion years our species
arose fully a couple hundred thousand
years ago we each have something
usually less than 100 years of life it
is our only
opportunity to be
conscious
and it is
a tiny tiny tiny
blip and that blip has been interrupted
by fools
who decided that in order to prevent a
pandemic that they
feared from happening that they had to
risk creating it
they then risked creating it they then
lost
control of it and they have compromised
humanity to an incalculable degree
right that we have a new virus that we
may never be rid of that we may
repeatedly get sick with across our
lives
is such a colossal error
and the idea that these same people who
made this colossal error about which we
had no we didn't even know weren't even
aware they were doing it until it had
already escaped the barn
right that these people are in a
position to mandate what you and i do in
the face of a vaccine that they have
done nothing but lie to us about
right it's just
it is it is a it is a biblical tragedy
right it is a shakespearean level
tragedy yeah and alongside that um
you know sort of
geopolitical pharmaceutically corporate
sort of impetus
and failure
i think are some other um flaws that
have gripped us on an epidemic level i
mean we are we are are paralyzed by fear
and it's not clear i mean
i think a lot of people in our country
anyway are talking about i can't wait
till the mandates lift as though that
will restore us back to where we were
but that's not
a remedy for the fear that put us here
that's not a remedy for the complacency
that it'll that allowed
our situation to become
rabid and entrenched
it's not a therapeutic for
the coercion that we allow to take place
and the norm
the normalization
of things like
nudge and behavioral insights propaganda
at a national level
it none of those things get fixed when
the mandates are lifted none of those
things get fixed if covet is magically
eradicated
no those are psychologi those are those
are not just individual psychological
problems but those are group
psychological problems and now with
globalization on a global scale
so how do we address
the these
psychological
weaknesses and crutches within the whole
human race
that are now
coming back to what we started with in
our universities being taught as virtues
yeah we um
we had something
deeply flawed but highly functional
right something that could have been
repaired and instead of looking at what
was wrong with it and being realistic
about
how to fix it and what rate we could
reasonably expect it to get better
we
foolishly allowed ourselves to become
unmoored
and i don't think people have yet
understood how dangerous it is to be
unmoored in history that we have we have
cut ourselves loose
and we are now adrift
and what we cannot say
is where we will land we cannot say that
we will land anywhere at all right our
species is fragile
and the fact is our continued existence
was
dependent on certain agreements that we
had reached about how to treat each
other about how
processes are required to change
and then suddenly
suddenly we're in an era where we're
seeing
just absolutely
processes that are absolutely
antithetical to the fundamental nature
of the west being deployed willy-nilly
over
trucker protests right they're going
after bank accounts using these
electronic
blocks it's it's just absolutely
unbelievable with all the protections
built into our system that we would
allow this to take place and that we
would think
that we could
go back i mean your your point is
exactly right the the disappearance of
the mandates
don't mean anything because the real
story is that we've become unmoored and
we do not know where we're gonna land
you know
and then i wonder why is that how have
we gotten ourselves so unmoored as you
say are so unhooked from from the past
and it seems like we we are connected to
people now but only across
space and not time
right so we are only connected with
other
current people in the moment
right on february 24th to 2022 we're
connected to them in a sense that we
text with them where we read about
what's happening to them in other parts
of the world or whatever
but we're disconnected in time from
humans that have come before us and um
you know
if you think about the the abandonment
of the oral tradition once the printing
press was invented there was a big law i
mean there was something gained there
but there was so good books we could
share knowledge that way but i think
what was probably lost in that moment in
time
was a forced connection with our
ancestors and with the events of the
past and with the lessons of the past
and it was preserved in these these
fables and tales and and tales of heroes
and tales of loss and
um now we don't
i mean not only do we not have
an oral tradition but i don't know if
we're even interested in our written
histories
um
[Music]
and and without that i mean we you know
the the reluctance to compare what's
going on now to what happened in nazi
germany
is not just a concern
about um
trampling insensitively
on the horrors of what happened to the
jewish people and other people in 1930s
and 40s germany it's not just a moral
transgression
i think the concern is that maybe the
underlying concern
is with
as soon as we make an analogy between
what's happening now in any moment in
the past
we're forcing a connection that we've
really lost already
and we don't know how to do it
yeah i i take this one very personally
i was born in 1969 which at the time
seemed a long way
from
nazi germany and i now realize it wasn't
very long at all
and you know as a jewish kid
my elders
made very sure
that my generation understood that it
could happen here it can happen anywhere
and you probably thought they were crazy
no i listened
what i didn't get what i never once
thought was that it could happen
everywhere
right i always thought
it can happen somewhere and the thing is
you don't want to be late
to escape it
i didn't think it was going to happen
everywhere but
i know that over all those
years we've developed a sensitivity to
analogizing that the holocaust has
become too sacred in a sense that we're
not allowed to invoke it because people
have been too careless in doing so
but my feeling is
a lot of people are now comforted by the
fact that what they see
doesn't look like nazi germany it
doesn't goose step it doesn't wear
skulls on its hats
right it's there's something comforting
about the fact that it doesn't look nazi
but i don't think we should be comforted
at all
because
let's put it this way i don't know the
devil what is the saying the devil you
don't see is a lot worse than the one
that you do something like that i mean
the idea that it's almost sort of hiding
in plain sight or something
right hiding in plain sight hiding in
the form of tony fauci who just really
doesn't look like a nazi
right
but
the thing that spooks me
is
that when i go looking for analogies for
the forced vaccination program for
example
it doesn't land exactly on tuskegee
it doesn't land exactly on mangala
but i know that that's the quadrant of
the library that i'm forced to search
right right that there is no better
analogy and i think my my sense is
a
i think
because of the
history of persecution for jews
that jews have an obligation actually to
speak to this point and that if anybody
is allowed to violate the rules about
invoking the holocaust it ought to be us
that that's something we've earned
i think my point is look i'm not saying
this is exactly that but i am saying
anytime you are forced into that part of
the library to look for analogies
that's that's nature's way of telling
you something has gone very seriously
wrong
and i know
i know that's the quadrant of the
library i know it's that quadrant and i
know that in the fiction it's 1984 it's
brazil it's kafka
it's fahrenheit 451. anytime you are
forced into that quadrant of the library
you need to think very carefully about
how you got there and what you could do
to undo it
and
i think go ahead well i was just going
to say and what's the point of making an
analogy anyway i mean usually it's so
that we're we're illustrating something
or we're learning a lesson from
something so if we're going through an
experience that's a bit um intractable
to us or we don't quite understand we
look to something else that shares
enough analogs in common
and then if we maybe understand that
second scenario better we can hope to
impart import some of the lessons from
that second scenario into our own that
we don't understand very well so that we
can understand it better so it's
illuminating it's very
um
it's a
it's a very worthwhile project if you do
it carefully and thoughtfully
and you've
made sure to
pick another scenario with enough
analogs and the reason
you know
as you may know i mean there was this um
member of parliament in the house
melissa lassman who is jewish she's a
descendant of holocaust survivors i
think survivors don't quote me on that
but
um
and and you know the our prime minister
accused her of standing with nazis and
those waving swastikas
and um
you know it's
it's almost like we've we've sort of
lost the capacity to understand
what she's worried about
or even what our prime minister is
worried about because if we are making
that analogy to a nazi regime of the
past well why is that why are we worried
about the not what is nazism anyway
and yes there's the whole um racial
purification eugenics aspect of it but
basically
i mean my understanding is that what the
what the nazis are it's a it's a kind of
fascism that despises liberal democracy
it despises all things that are about
freedom of the individual
and if what we're feeling in this moment
is the greatest threat that we
who are living now have ever felt to our
ability to live as a free person
then trying to learn some lessons from
maybe the most recent moment in history
that we know of or the most punctuated
moment of history that we're aware of
where liberal democracy and the rights
and freedoms of individuals was most at
threat if if that's where we have to go
in history to understand ourselves
better
then that doesn't seem to be that that's
not only
um not irresponsible but it would be
irresponsible not to do that right
so
i think i can i can uh
put some flesh on those bones a little
bit because
my sense and this is definitely not the
consensus in my field
but my sense as an evolutionary
biologist is that what we are looking at
is a conflict between two levels of
evolutionary well-being
and that
the ancient one is based on genes right
the reason that you as a 30 trillion
cell creature work is that all your
cells have the same genes and so they
are in perfect agreement about you
operating as a cohesive something or
other
a population
of people that is very closely
genetically related has a similar reason
to collaborate and to self-sacrifice in
order to move through time
but there is a second reason a much
better reason
which has to do with the
profitability of collaborating
irrespective of how genetically related
you are to someone
right the university is a marvelous
example of this right you gather with
people
of every color
and both sexes and many different styles
of training many different origin
stories and you talk about
what is true and what it means
and you don't think about the fact that
i want that person to succeed because
they're more closely related to me than
that other person right we reciprocate
because the profitability for all of us
is so much better than becoming obsessed
with genetic relatedness
and the problem is
that the nazis
were reverting
to this other reason for collaboration a
genetic reason for collaboration
and any time we are faced with that
spasm
that ancient evolutionary
force trying to overwhelm
our modern enlightened cosmopolitan
belief that it makes sense to put genes
aside and to collaborate with people
irrespective of where they come from we
are in danger of
going backwards in history
that's why it's important anytime this
pops up it is
the
ancient relatedness
trying to overwhelm the modern
enlightenment and we have an obligation
to defend the enlightenment with
everything we've got because it truly is
superior
it was it's a hard-won
gain and our children are entitled to it
and that that's what we're facing that's
why
you and i have been driven out of the
university system that is why
we now have friends demonizing us for
choices about medical autonomy right it
is that ancient
backwards
way of seeing things threatening to
overwhelm the hard-won gains of the last
couple thousand years
it's really very i mean it's tragic as
we've been saying but it's also very
beautiful that that story you know of
how we're
we're failing and if if we are failing
if we are
somewhere on a slope that has a downward
trajectory the bottom of which we have
not
met yet
um
you know we are i think we are now a
story of a of a demoralized people we
have and i mean that very literally i
mean we are demoralized we have lost
what um
makes humans capable of being
moral beings and and that's things like
it's not just sort of moral um virtues
like like goodness and courage and
generosity and not just psychological
capacities like empathy and openness and
humility and things like that but also
intellectual capacities like reason
and memory
and
critical thinking as we've been
discussing and if we are really
demoralized if we've lost
the capacity to be moral beings
how do you treat those people what is
the appropriate remedy well punishing
them further
dividing them further
ostracizing them from
one another and what matters to them
further is only going to plummet us
further into this inhuman demoralized
kind of abyss and what what demoralized
people need is is a kind of moral care
so we can rebuild our integrity our
system of wholeness but not just for
ourselves but between one another and so
we need to learn how
you know how is it that our virtues of
tolerance patience generosity friendship
from a civic point of view were turned
on their heads so that now we normalize
and prioritize things like intolerance i
mean the more intolerant you are the
quicker you can dismiss an outlier from
your sphere your social sphere the
better you are
we need to
understand how
to revert that to revert back to that i
think older system of virtues that have
proven themselves over the millennia
to be more
successful not just i think from an
evolutionary strategy as you would uh
understand or say but
in terms of what's better at
creating human flourishing you know i my
area of specialty is aristotle and
aristotle was a virtue ethicist and he
tried to understand
you know what is it that makes people
happy
and for him it's a kind of flourishing
it's a kind of you know like the
wholeness of a human being needs to
function optimally and that's why
virtue comes from the greek word arete
for excellence so to be virtuous is to
be excellent in all the ways that humans
are capable of being excellent right
it's to develop reason to the best of
our ability it's to develop our
capacities for uh emotional
understanding to the best of our
abilities and so
when we separate ourselves from each
other when we start hating and dividing
each other when we're falling into this
abyss it's not just
that that's
bad for the individual but we're
breaking the integrity of the social
system and now we're seeing the results
of that we see protests in in in canada
and now you have truckers driving across
your country and then i mean we've been
talking for two hours i haven't looked
to see what's going on in the ukraine
but i hate i mean
our world is falling apart and i think
that's because we have a threat we don't
just have this viral threat we have a
threat to the integrity
of our moral systems as individuals and
our moral relatedness to other people
right
yes and we have the oddness of
this technological moment
so i don't know about you but i've had
the experience of
losing
my career losing a good portion of
my friend group
losing my home
but
for each of the things that i have lost
i have been put in contact with
absolutely
marvelous people that i never would have
encountered otherwise people like you
that i've never met
in person but you and i are capable of
having this conversation and you know
look i wouldn't know that you existed
but for the fact that we had
been thrown out of the same academy
at different times for different crimes
and uh
i guess
this is the thing i hope people will
understand is that the horror
of what is happening of us losing track
of who we are and what we've learned and
what it means
is only matched by the unusual
fact of the dissidents
being driven together and discovering
each other in a way that would have been
impossible until
i don't know
50 years ago
right and
there is a tremendous
amount of
solace in discovering the high quality
people who have said no
and
have been ejected and are now just
becoming aware of
the parallel others i find something
um as as
dystopian as this moment is i find
something very hopeful
in uh in all of the marvelous people who
who have been forced to the surface by
it it's a beautiful kind of poetic irony
in some sense it's also it's very sad to
me when i hear people who have been hurt
by what's happened over the last couple
of years by the mandates or whatever
social ostracization or whatever that
they speak as though
sadness and badness in life are
inevitable as a result of these things
as though
and you know that's coupled with
language like i'm i'm forced to make a
certain choice i'm forced to
abide by the mandates or whatever but i
think
you know one of the things that that
that the story that you are telling
shows is that
we can be
coerced we can be manipulated we can
face pressures from all sides that make
us feel like our uh scope of choice is
not what it was
but we cannot be forced to be other than
what we want to be in our
souls that is a place that is immune to
all external influence unless we allow
it
that is true immunity
right yeah
what what we've seen is i mean i i i'm
not insensitive to um
moral hardship and the challenges with
resilience over time i mean i think
we've seen that
uh in the indigenous community that it's
you know you're you can be beaten down
enough and it is very hard to recover
from that
but also the the circumstances the
circumstances that you described show us
that you can have these beautiful
phoenix from the ashes or whatever you
want to call it moments at the worst
times you could never have planned it
the human mind i think is not capable of
orchestrating that kind of spontaneous
beauty and all we can do is i think be
on the lookout for it
and embrace it when it happens and try
to make the best best of it
yeah that's a a very
poetic way of putting it and i think
there is something
it's accidental i'm sure but
symbolic
about a society that has grown so sick
that it believes it has a right to
dictate the reprogramming of your immune
system
and has a dick a right to dictate the
reprogramming of your mind and i must
say
i am very pleased to see
how many people understand that that is
wrong
who are standing up and saying look you
can take everything else but you can't
take that what's inside my mind
is mine and it's it's it's not your
right this is the one life i'm going to
get and i'm entitled to use my mind as i
see fit
and uh
thank you
um
well is there anything else you'd like
to say before we wrap this up we've been
through conservatively two millennia of
human history and three and a half
billion years of the history of life on
the planet so i can't think of anything
else
you're right we did we did cover a lot
we did cover a lot
very thoroughly enjoyable thank you yes
it's been a lovely conversation
where can people find you
so i am now the pandemic ethics scholar
for the democracy fund which is a civil
liberties charity in canada so people
can go to the democracyfund.ca
i also have a new book out called my
choice uh so you can go to
mychoicebook.ca or find it on amazon and
on instagram i'm dr julie panesi i think
i'm also that on twitter so i'm around
excellent well i will
put links to all of those things in the
description i very much look forward to
hearing what people have to say about
our conversation i think it was a very
good one and i think the feedback will
be fascinating
um so until we talk again
good luck to you thank you for doing
this and
to everyone else we'll see you next time